he's a New York Times bestselling author
ESPN commentator and you can see him on
the SEC network and heard on ESPN Radio
host of the Paul Finebaum show on Sirius
XM all joins us on the program how would
you sum up the week in college football
this week Paul it was tumultuous Dan
with so many different things going on
from the social unrest piece of the
puzzle to rising Kobuk rates in Texas
Anthony Falchi here yesterday pouring a
little cold water on the positivity
train it was not a good week in
particular Oklahoma State with Mike
Gundy is he talking himself out of
trouble or talking himself into even
more trouble I think into being a
commentator on some Network fairly soon
because I don't think he can last much
longer I mean he started the week off in
bad shape and then he kept talking and
talking I'm not gonna quote Shakespeare
about the protesting too much because he
really never made any sense and he went
from wearing a one America News Network
t-shirt which which seemed innocuous
even though he has supported it in the
past
- then disparaging them after
acknowledging that he didn't really
understand why his players were so upset
I mean it was it was a incalculably bad
week for my Gundy and he you know it's
you know he really well-known for one
thing and he gave a memorable speech I'm
40 and I'm a man he's 50 now and he's a
buffoon if you ran Oklahoma State's
athletic program what would you do I
would get rid of him and it's not
because I'm a t-shirt I know I know a
lot of people on certain political
ideologies want to make it into that I
just think he's miscalculated so many
times he's embarrassed himself in the
university so many times and not to get
to actual football matters but he's 2
and 13 against Oklahoma dad that doesn't
work I mean I know John Cooper tried
that trick at Ohio State about 25 years
ago and finally caught up to him at some
point even though he's got a good record
by Oklahoma State Standards which is not
very high I think he needs to go yeah
when you go seven and six eight and five
the last two years that that that would
put you on thin ice certainly in in that
conference there but I get I'm waiting
to find out if his players are extrude
cepting of this because if they are then
that's their world that's their coach
and I would I would accept it from an
outsider looking in if I'm a player I
would not accept that and I would ask
for change if I could at Oklahoma State
yeah and I don't really think it's a
close call I mean sometimes these are
very narrow
these are 5-4 decision the Supreme Court
here on the DP show although I've always
wanted to cover the Supreme Court but I
mean they can do better
I mean I'd fire him just for the Mollett
alone man
you got Ole Miss on the clock now the
SEC is finally like what is what is the
state of Mississippi like the SEC
statement is basically saying to Ole
Miss what well it's interesting
I thought the Commissioner was
interesting in how he did it I mean he
went after the state flag which which
which has the Confederate flag in the
corner he avoided criticizing Ole Miss
whose nickname don't don't be shocked
here ban the rebels that one was not but
but here's where I think I mean if the
Commissioner of the SEC or somebody said
to the K a fraternity at Ole Miss you
can't have your rebel flag up when you
walk in or your old South Party which is
the biggest night of the year then I
think we're really having a serious
conversation I'm joking about that but
every you've been on fraternity row and
a million campuses and you you will see
a confederate flag and a lot of them
especially in that one but i think it
was symbolically it's a good it's a good
move
i'm not sure what it really means though
if it if it's going to have a lot of
impact his Ole Miss called Ole Miss is
Ole Miss on their helmets next season
if we have a season probably not and I
don't know how we play football I know
that everybody keeps saying hey football
you got time to figure this out you got
a hundred players on these teams Paul I
mean it if you just do the math I do I
think it's wishful I think it's optimist
optimism but I'm not even cautiously
optimistic I'm just cautious with all of
this Paul Dan I I've interviewed every
commissioner in college football a
couple of times now every athletic
director and they all say we're very
hopeful we're optimistic it sounds like
you're at the the Paris peace talks from
50 years ago that we had a very very
very very substantive meeting at the
bottom wise nobody wants to be the
person who says we're not going to have
college football Kirk Herbstreit about
eight weeks ago came came out and he
said we're not having college football
and he hasn't been seen since I mean
he's he's been in a bunker and he's
afraid to come out because you don't
want to be that guy I mean there are
people who I've just read you know
well-known commentators assassinating
Anthony Fauci scare credibility because
he he came on and said it's doubtful I
don't know how you do it I agree with
you and I'm like I'm not I'm not my
decision I'm a commentator and talk-show
host like you are but I think it's an
incredibly strong a big challenge and
not only are some saying we're going to
have it
yeah there's athletic directors in Texas
saying we're going to have 50 to 75%
capacity in the stands I mean that's
even more outrageous to consider than
even having a season which you could
start a season maybe I think the
challenge what everyone says you're
getting to the end of it talking to Paul
Finebaum at the mothership I was
wondering about this and I proposed this
I don't even know what day it is but you
know months ago can you have the
students go back in August and they go
to Thanksgiving and then you could have
football start as I know the students
gonna want to be there for football but
if you're trying this about money this
is all about money and you know
certainly with the NFL certainly with
Bay
you know maybe college is not as
heavy-handed but can I squeeze in a
college football season that starts
after Thanksgiving and still
accomplished maybe it's an abbreviated
season what's the likelihood of college
football starting later than earlier
yeah I mean I think I think though
though college football people will
start it whenever they have to start it
they don't care but the problem the
problem with that though is it's a it's
about a 15-week season under normal
circumstances and if you started then
you're really in a more dangerous time
of the year for for not only Kovac but
for the flu you know that's the peak of
the flu season and I don't want to sound
like I know know too much about this
island to be married to a doctor so I
hear it every night and she looks at me
like are you talking about having her
college football season every on your
show but I don't know I mean the truth
is they're going to try I mean I think I
had a person telling me this to show you
how crazy it is I had a person tell me
that something that some coaches are
hoping that all these players will get
it so there maybe so maybe they won't
get it again and you can have the season
but yeah I don't know if that makes any
sense it obviously doesn't but can we
trust college coaches to even be honest
about these tests once we get to the
season I mean you talked about getting
ready for the Ohio State Michigan game
the Alabama Auburn game the Georgia
Florida game our coach is going to say
I'm sorry my star player tested positive
I'm gonna quarantine him in the
offensive line
I mean I college football is ripe with
with with lying and cheating and and
fraudulence and and deception and I and
I don't think this would be any
different yeah I'm right there with you
Ben and I have we joked about it you
know that you know maybe knowing Saban
hey everybody gets six so then we're
ready and nobody else is ready you know
a team activity come on out we're gonna
tomorrow everybody go to the lake house
we're gone it's a it's a corona party in
more ways than one come on in it's on me
but you know we're gonna be like Sweden
I
just don't I'd I want to have college
football but that doesn't mean we're
gonna have college football if I said
starting on time
the odds of starting on time for all of
these conferences is what I think I
think some will start on Labor Day
weekend and I know I'm not giving you a
damn beep and the answer I don't think
everyone will and I think that's where
the dysfunctionality of the season will
begin the only thing that will stop that
is this that students start arriving
back on campus in late August and the
problem just met just blows up in
college presidents like the one at
michigan who spoke out a couple weeks
ago just say you know what we can't do
it and then there's a trickle-down
effect but but right now it's just like
politics nobody wants to speak up in
Washington DC and it's the same in
college athletics nobody wants to be the
one that stops and asked the question
what are we doing here is this really
safe all they're really see all they
seem to be doing is let's get to the
season so we can start cashing those TV
network checks Paul great to talk to you
hope you're well and thanks for joining
us Dan always a pleasure be well that's
Paul Finebaum of the mothership
New York Times bestselling author and of
course host of the Paul Finebaum show on
Sirius XM